[MUSIC PLAYING]
OMAR AYOUB: Cool, so
welcome again to Developing
Made Easy, nothing to do with
microphone or presentations
though.
So we'll talk about,
ultimately, tools, libraries.
We're trying to make your
life easier as a developer
and make the developing
experience simpler
for you guys.
So whether you're new to GCP
or you've used it for a while,
we think that everybody here
has a thing or two actually
to learn from this talk so you
can again, be more productive.
So we can just get
started right ahead.
But before, some
quick introductions.
Quick introductions,
my name is Omar Ayoub.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud
and I focus on the
developer experience
and specifically on
client libraries.
And I'm from Seattle,
Washington and I
love to travel
international affairs
and I have the pleasure of
being joined with Aylin.
AYLIN ALTIOK: Thanks, Omar.
Hi everyone.
My name is--
OMAR AYOUB: Yeah, you
might want to use this one.
AYLIN ALTIOK: Sorry.
Hi everyone.
My name is Aylin Altiok.
I'm also a product manager in
Google Cloud Platform focusing
on Cloud SDK.
I live in New York City
and on a personal note,
I love sailing as
well as traveling.
OMAR AYOUB: That's
the slide you wanted.
Great, so that's why we
both traveled here today,
to talk to you about
developer experience.
So specifically, what you
can expect from today's talk
is I will take you on a
whirlwind tour of developer
tools.
So, we have a lot of them.
We won't touch on everything.
But we're really going
to focus on three mainly.
The Cloud Shell, we'll talk
about some of the workflows
that that enables
as well for you.
We'll talk about the
Cloud SDK, and Aylin's
going to walk us through
that. that's a set of tools
and libraries we have in Cloud.
And then we will talk about the
Cloud Client Libraries, which
are there to basically allow
you to have programmatic access
to our APIs.
So before we jump into every
artifact, just a quick visual
about where the developer tools
fall within the context of GCP.
So we have the tools
at the bottom here
and the idea is that they
allow you to access the GCP
services as you would expect.
And we have a lot of services.
This is just a
sample, the hexagons
show you specific services.
And the purpose here, the idea
is to make it simple and easy,
depending on what you're
trying to achieve.
You'll notice that we
separated those services
into two buckets.
This is not a hard thing.
Just for the purposes of this
talk, it helps visualize.
On the one side, we
have the platforms.
So by platform, we
mean things where
you want to run your code.
So on the one hand,
we have App Engine.
This is our platform as
a service offering, which
allows you ultimately
to run your code
and not worry about
anything else.
So you write your
code, you deploy it,
and then you're up and running.
Now the thing is, we have
two flavors of App Engine
and I just mentioned that
because we will be referring
to this during the talk.
We have App Engine standard,
which is a sandbox environment.
We have App Engine Flex,
which is based on containers.
If you've used GCP
before, you're familiar.
This is all known
to you, but just
to be sure we're
on the same page.
And then we have
Container Engine.
This is basically
a Cluster Manager
for your Docker Containers.
So you specify your
Docker Containers
and then we scale up,
we scale down for you
as a managed service.
Now one of the cool
developer tools
here in Workflow that we have
that we won't touch on today
but I encourage
you to look into,
is you can use
Container Builder, which
just went generally
available very recently.
You can use that to build
your container images, which
then will get saved to Container
Registry, also in the Cloud.
It's a registry for your
docker container images,
and then you can run
this on Container Engine
as a nice workflow
from end to end.
So I encourage you
to go look into that
for Container Builder.
And finally, we also
have Compute Engine.
This is basically
our infrastructure
as a service offering.
So you want a VM,
we'll give you a VM
and you have full
control basically
of what you want to
install and what not.
So again, the idea here is
that developer tools allow
you to manage these
resources, to push good on it,
and you can see how
CLIs or command line
interfaces might be the
good solution for this part.
Then on the other
side we have our APIs.
We have Translation,
Storage, BigQuery.
Ultimately, you want
to get data when
your application is running.
You want to save in a table.
You want to analyze
a piece of text
using the Cloud
Natural Language API.
All of that, you would use
obviously programmatic access
and client libraries is
where you'll probably
want to go in and
be able to do this.
And of course your application
running using these APIs
could be running on
one of the platforms
or it could be running locally
or running on another platform.
Great.
Given that context, we
can now start and talk
about our different artifacts.
So quick story actually, I
came to SF like two days ago.
I flew down from Seattle.
So I'm in the airplane in
the aisle doing my work.
So I have my laptop.
It has all my
developer tools on it.
I've been using it
for a year and a half
so I have all my languages,
all my GCP tools.
I'm doing my work and
then out of nowhere--
and this is a true story, by
the way-- on my left hand,
I start noticing some Coke
appearing then on my hand
and then on my laptop and,
like, all over my laptop.
And I look up and the actual
flight attendant by mistake
just dropped everything
on my laptop.
I always wondered if
that actually happened.
But it actually
does, so heads up.
This might happen to you.
So I get back to SF.
I'm like, great.
Obviously my data's all
backed up, but I'm like,
I have to get a new machine
and reinstall everything.
And for me to be even
productive minimally,
I have to do all of that.
And my first thought was, if
only I could log on somewhere
and have everything preinstall
and I can just hook up my data
and I'll be up and running.
Anyways, kind of
wishful thinking.
But then I realized, this is
exactly what Cloud Shell does.
So in reality, Cloud
Shell, no kidding,
is a command line interface
where you log on in the Cloud
and you literally get access
to a bunch of GCP tools
and you can start being
productive right away.
So by the way, this
was not a set up story.
This actually happened and
it just clicked in my mind,
this is amazing.
This is perfect timing for this.
So literally, what
actually happens
is you only need a browser.
You log on, nothing
to install locally,
and right there, you have a
bunch of tools pre-installed.
And by tools, they
mean like text editors,
we have Emacs,
VIM, you have Nano.
You have Git preinstalled,
the Cloud SDK,
which is a bunch of CLIs.
And Aylin will talk about
that a little bit later.
But everything is
pre-installed up to date,
you have nothing to do.
And we support seven
languages out of the box.
So we have Java, Go, Dot
Net, Node, PHP, Python, Ruby,
the interpreters, the
compilers, the package managers,
you can do pip install,
it's all there.
And the beauty is that it
has built in authorization
so no need to log on again.
You can just execute
and it just works.
I could give you guys
more and more features,
but it would probably be
easier if I just show you
how it works in the console.
So we'll switch to demo.
Lovely.
So what we're
looking at right now
is literally the main landing
page when you log onto GCB.
If you've done this before,
this is not new to you.
You're looking at projects
and every Cloud resource
you create will be
within a project.
So to manage these resources,
if you go to the top left corner
and you click on that,
you'll see a menu
with basically a bunch of--
so if you click on that,
you will see a menu
with a bunch of the
services, some of which
we talked about earlier.
App Engine and Compute
Engine, Container Engine.
Anyways, the point
being is that you
can use that to do your
management through the UI.
But like we talked, what if you
want to run some automation,
you want to write
some code, you want
to-- well you'll probably
need a shell for that.
So if you go to the
top right corner,
you'll notice there's
an Activate Cloud Shell.
You click on that and that
will start the Cloud Shell.
So what happens
in the background,
just to let you know, is that
a virtual machine, a small one,
gets created and it has
all the tools pre-installed
right there.
And what it does is it mounts
five gigabytes of storage
that you own.
So every person
here, when you log on
with your Google account, you
get 5 gig of persisted disk
storage for free.
And that gets mounted as your
home directory in the Cloud
Shell because it's
mounted on the VM.
So if you do a PWD,
for example, you
will see that we're in the
home directory of where we are.
And everything you save in
there will get persisted.
So if you log off, you
come back in a week,
everything you
save will be there.
So you can see how you can
start writing scripts, writing
automation, writing some code,
everything will be saved.
And also just to show you if
we do get dash dash version,
you'll see that we have
that installed as well.
Now, we talked about
VIM, talk about Emacs.
There's always a big war between
the two, which one's better.
We have a solution
[INAUDIBLE] which
is basically to go in
the top left corner,
you'll see here files.
And if you click on
launching the code editor,
this is experimental right
now but this is basically
a UI for you to be able to do
coding directly in the browser.
So if you're more into that
and using a user interface,
this is what you can do.
And notice here that
what we're looking at
is your home directory
also mounted.
So whatever you save
in there will get
persisted again
just like earlier.
It's the same view.
So we talked about
having the tools,
we talked about
having a code editor.
Everything is pre-set up.
We have five gigabytes of space.
So in the next part, we'll just
really create a very small web
app in Python just to show
you what can actually be done.
And it will walk through
some of the workflows
so you can get a better idea
of what's enabled directly
from the console again without
installing anything locally.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So we'll create a new
app we'll call it My App.
And that will be a Python web
app, so exactly very simple.
So first thing we'll do,
we'll create a main.py,
and that will contain
our main code.
Now we could go ahead
and do that but if you're
familiar with App
Engine Standard,
we do have a quick start in
there that explains to you
exactly how to get started and
this is exactly where we're
going to go and copy that code.
Again, the goal is to
make it very simple
just to show you the other
tools that we have around that.
So in this case, you see that
we have a very simple web
application.
We'll copy that in.
And what it does
is imports webapp2
which is a app engine
standard web framework.
Then we register a get handler
where we just print out
Hello World, where
we could change that
to Hello Next for instance.
And then we're going
to register the app--
for the handler, I mean.
So that is done, we're done.
That is the simplest possible
web app we can do in Python.
But given that we want to run
this on App Engine Standard,
and you'll see that
in a second, we're
going to have to create
an app.yaml file.
So we'll just create
this new file.
This is very typical.
It's just a way of telling
App Engine by the way,
your platform has a
service but you still
need to know what type
of application I am.
So going back to
the quick start,
if you want to go
and look, I encourage
you to take a look at it.
Very simple.
And you'll see
that we register--
or simply tell App
Engine that's Python
and we tell that what
handlers we have registered.
That's it, we're done.
So we can go back
to the Cloud Shell.
We've literally built an app.
So if we do an LS,
you see that we
have a My App folder
saved in our 5
gigabyte of persistent storage.
We can log into
that or CD to that.
And then at this
point, something else
that's installed--
pre-installed for you
is the tooling for
App Engine Standard.
So one of which
being dev app server.
So this is just a tool allowing
you to do local testing.
So dev app server, we pass
in the app.yaml, hit Enter,
and this basically
will start on the VM
locally the actual web app.
Now do notice that it's
listening on port 8080.
But if we went on the
browser now on port 8080,
we'd be connecting
to this machine.
We want to connect to a VM.
Well, in the top left
corner of the Cloud Shell,
you'll notice there's a
button where you can click
and you have a web preview.
And that allows you to
connect to port 8080
only to your account
on that machine
and you see that very
seamlessly it just works.
We can have Hello Next,
we can do-- obviously,
you can make this
much more complicated.
This is just to get
things going quickly.
So we have this.
Imagine we love this app,
it's exactly what we wanted.
And now we want to deploy
to App Engine Center.
We want to make it live.
So for that we can just kill the
application here at the testing
and go ahead and do
GCloud app deploy.
Now we talked about
GCloud a little bit
because it's part
of the Cloud SDK
but Aylin will give more
details a little bit later.
So GCloud is basically
a command line interface
that allows you to interact
with the Cloud services.
In this case, app
means App Engine.
So it allows you to interact
with the App Engine service.
Deploy, to deploy our
app we pass in app.yaml.
And then we'll just do
dash dash version 2.
This is not mandatory
but you'll see later,
we want to know the version.
And versions, I just made up
something, so we can hit Enter.
Lovely.
So this will run the background.
Now one thing we forgot
to do, by the way
and we should probably do that
right now is version control.
Best practice,
let's do thisl well.
Notice there's a plus
button right next, up here
we can create a
new shell session.
So you click on that,
we start a new session.
And now we can run
the get commands.
So we do a CD into
My App and then
we'll just do the typical
get dance like get in it,
get at star, and then we'll just
do a get initial commit or get
commit dash M. Perfect,
initial commit, great.
So just to show that you
can do obviously local repo,
because if you guys
will get persisted.
However, what if you want to
collaborate with other people,
right?
Like software engineering,
you're actually
building an app you want
to share with others,
you probably use
GitHub or Bitbucket,
and I like to use Bitbucket
for my private projects.
But in this case,
perhaps something
you didn't know
about, is that we
do have private Git repositories
in Google Cloud Platform
and it's called a Cloud
Source repositories.
So in a new tab, if you click
on it, you go in the menu,
you go lower down you'll find
under Tools something called
development.
If you click on that, this
is literally a fully featured
private git repo.
So we can create a new repo,
we'll call it stage repo,
and that is ultimately
a remote repository.
Now, just to let you know,
as an FYI, if you wanted to,
you could still have stuff
in Bitbucket or Github,
and then automatically sync
back to this repo, by the way.
So that you can
keep both in sync,
and there are advantages
to that as we'll see later,
especially when
you use App Engine.
But for now, we'll do
the typical workflow.
Right.
We have our local
repository, and we're
going to push everything
to this remote repository.
So if we click on, I guess,
repository on the left,
we can just copy
paste the remote URL,
go back to Cloud shell, and
get remote ad, call it Google
and pass in the URL,
and then we'll just
do a git push Google
master, right?
And just for completeness,
once this finishes,
we'll head back to
the repo and show you
how all the files have been
ultimately, have been pushed.
Beautiful.
And you have everything you
would expect here, right?
You would have commit
history, you have branches,
you can have tags,
everything's there.
Do disk between files,
it's all up in here.
OK, how we doing on
App Engine center?
Did it deploy?
Let's see.
It did.
Awesome.
So this is basically
now live URL.
I know it took a
couple of minutes,
not even actually because
we were switching,
and whatever we wrote is now
live on App Engine standard.
So a quick recap here, right.
We have the Cloud Shell,
bunch of tools are installed,
you can start coding,
start developing.
You have the Code Editor
to do that, then we
do a bunch of gits, we pushed
to a source repository.
We were able to test
locally, we were
able to push the
App Engine center.
The last thing that we're
going to do in this workflow
is debug it.
So we'll go back to a tab
and maybe you're not aware
of this is probably one of my
favorite features, by the way,
in products.
You go to sac driver de-bug.
Now what we're looking
at here is literally
a debugger in the cloud.
So, we're connected
to GCP, right?
If you notice here, there's a
job done that says default/2.
Remember when we
specified the version 2?
This is where it shows up.
It's called default because
we didn't specify a name
to our App Engine application.
But if you want to, the
name will show up here.
It picks up the
App Engine running,
and on the left-hand
side, you see the files.
Because we used Cloud
source repository,
it can pick up the
files there as well
and do the connection
between the App Engine
running the code, and the files
checked in in the source repo.
So now we're looking
actually at the code
that we wrote, we copy pasted.
And then we're going to put a
snapshot point at some line.
Do realize that I didn't say a
break point, because we're not
breaking the app.
What's going to happen
here is that we're
telling App Engine,
hey, please when
you see the code
or the application
executing this code
path, take a snapshot.
Take a snapshot of the
call stack take a snapshot
of the local variables.
Send it back to me.
So if you open the
live URL that we
have for App
Engine, hit refresh,
it will execute the git, right?
We go back, snapshot was hit.
If you look in the
lower right corner,
you'll see the call stack.
You'll see the local
variables, everything you need.
And just to be clear,
we didn't stop the app,
app is still running.
We didn't have to create another
version to put log statements,
this is live happening directly.
And if you wanted to, you can
also put a conditional snapshot
point.
So yeah.
So that was basically the
full end to end workflow.
We can switch back
to the slides now.
So, quick recap.
I just said it but
really quickly,
the stuff you might want
to look into a bit more
are the Cloud Shell, comes with
a code editor, an experimental,
but it'll get better.
It will obviously move to
beta and everything else.
We have App Engine.
We have source repositories.
And we have the site
[INAUDIBLE] de-bug.
And all of that
without logging on,
with only logging on without
installing anything locally.
As simple as we can make it.
Now if you think this is
really neat, but is there more?
The answer is yes there
is Cloud Shell Pro.
So right, now
actually, at next we
have an alpha version open
only to next attendees.
So you can have a bigger
VM, more CPU, more ram.
So if you're
interested, I highly
suggest going to this
bit.ly link, shell-pro.
It's a small form,
you can fill it out
and we'll reach out to you.
And please, you can
give us feedback.
Let us know what you like.
Let us know what's missing.
Maybe more tools?
Whatever.
We want to hear from you.
Great.
With that being
said, now we can jump
to the next part,
which is the cloud SDK,
and Aylin will
explain that to us.
AYLIN ALTIOK: Thanks, Omar.
It was really cool to
see all those actions
you can do within browser
with no installation.
But what if you have a use
case to access all the services
within your local machine.
The Cloud SDK is your solution.
It contains a bunch
of command line tools
that lets you access the
Google Cloud Services.
For example, bq to
access big query,
gsutil to access storage,
and gcloud, which
is the primary
command line tool that
lets you access multiple
services like App
Engine, Compute Engine,
data PROC, mission learning
APIs, and many more.
Indeed I will focus on GCloud
for my rest of the demo,
but I'll also show
you the components
that you get when you
install Cloud SDK.
Configuration and
installation is super easy.
You can get it on
Linux, Mac or Windows.
Actually, with no
further slides,
I will go ahead and
jump into demo mode
so we can see Cloud
SDK in action.
Awesome.
So I'll just search, the
first thing we have to do
is to install it.
So I'll just search
Cloud SDK Install,
and we will go ahead the
installation documentation
here.
And you will see there are
a couple options that you
can get it through zip file,
or you can get it interactively
by running the call command.
So if you haven't
done so, I highly
recommend you start
your installation.
I already installed
it prior to demo,
so I'm not going to do that,
but let's start together.
The next step you have
to do after installation
is initializing Cloud SDK.
So in order to do
that, we are going
to run GCloud in it's comments.
So let me go back to my terminal
and let's run GCloud in it.
So, this command, what
this command will do
is that it's going to
create a new configuration,
or if you have only the
existing configuration,
you can also switch in here.
But I created one
configuration before,
but let's start a
new one together.
So this will let us,
this command will let
us set up our project, our SDK.
So we can talk to
cloud services online.
So first thing we have
to do is to give a name,
the configuration.
You can create multiple,
and switch between,
and it's going to ask,
does the user name
we want to connect to services.
So I already used multiple
user names before,
but let's go out and
start with a new account.
So this is going
to open the browser
and let us to choose account.
So this is a demo
account we created
before, now Cloud SDK ask
for certain permissions
to access services.
Let's allow it, and boom, we
are authenticated to Cloud SDK.
If we go back to
our terminal now,
you'll notice that
we are getting
all the projects that was
created under these account
before.
So I created a project
before in the UI console.
Next I'm on GCloud,
so we will use it
for the rest of the demo.
And the last question is if you
want to set the Compute Engine
setting, this is going to
mainly ask us the zone,
so I'll go ahead
and set the zone
so we don't get prompted
for the zone in the feature,
but you can always
set the zone flag
or change it in the future.
So I'll just go out and select
US on a, hit that, and awesome.
We are all set and ready
to talk to sources now.
Let me clear it.
OK remember, I mentioned
to you Cloud SDK contains
a bunch of command line tools.
Let's go ahead and
verify which components
you get after you install.
So when I run GCloud
components, this command,
these are all the
components we see.
Some of them are installed by
default, like bq GAC2, GCloud,
and there are multiple more that
is not installed by default,
but if you have used
case, you can always
go ahead and run GCloud
components, update command,
and, for example,
cupsctl, and if you
have a use case DOCSIS
[INAUDIBLE] CLI,
you can go ahead and run this
command to update and install
those components.
So I'm not going to do that.
We are not going to focus on
that, but you get the idea.
And notice that
there are two, also
GCloud specific commands
under beta and alpha.
I installed this prior to demo.
These are not
installed by default,
but I will show you
a very cool feature
today under alpha commands which
is our experimental command
groups that we are
currently working on,
which is available to
public as long as you
installed this command group.
So I recommend you to get GCloud
components update to alpha,
and you notice here you
see also the version.
If your version is
pointing to old one,
you can always verify here
our team is launching versions
often, so I recommend you
to check and get the latest.
Perfect's, now we installed
SDK, we initialized it,
we check the components,
and we get the ones
that we are going to use.
Now what is next?
So we have to know which
command to run, right?
I assume some of
you may not know
how to run GCloud commands.
So there are two ways
you can figure it out
which commands to run.
The first thing could be
GCloud have, you can run it,
and this is going to bring
you basically the manual page,
the reference page to see
the flex that's available,
the command that is available.
You can see like
the app that you
use before to access App
Engine, Compute Engine
container, and so on.
Or you could do the same thing
by going to our reference page
here, and you see exactly
the same information,
if you prefer to
see it in browser.
But here is the problem.
If you are trying to basically
come up with the command
that you never used
before, or if you
are trying to discover new
services, so this context
switching between
the Manual page,
come back and continue
typing, may be inefficient
and time consuming.
In order to solve
this problem, we
have been working on a feature
called GCloud interactive shop,
which lets you get
auto prompting off
the commands and
the flags as you
type with inline documentation.
So you don't need to do
this context switching.
OK.
Let me show it.
So you get the idea.
Remember I mentioned
to you that I
have something cool to
show under alpha commands?
This is it.
And we are just
announcing it today.
So GCloud alpha
shell, if you run it,
this is going to bring
up the share mode.
You can see your
configuration at the bottom
here that we authenticated
our user name.
You see the project
that we picked up.
And now you can start using it.
So we don't know how to
use it, how about we create
a compute instance together.
So I just start by
typing c and it gives me
auto prompting of the commands
and I can go through them.
And in here, I see the
description of those
and I see the syntax
how to use it.
And if this information
is not enough,
since there is a
limited space, you
can always Control W to
open the full browser.
So before going to
compute user journey,
remember Omar mentioned earlier
that container builder ranked
generally available recently.
What if you want to learn
how to use that command?
So we will type container.
Let's space.
Let's hit space,
and this gets us
all the commands available
on the container service
so we can go through.
OK.
Builds is the one that we
want to run. and we hit space
and we get through all the
command groups under that.
And summit is the one that lets
you run your local docker file
and move it to a Container.
Registry.
Then you can deploy it to
your Container Engine after.
It's really cool that
we had no idea how
to run this command before,
but we can discover, basically,
the services this way.
And when you look at the
syntax, the next thing for us
to put the source
here, the docker
file source, or a dash dash
config or the tech flag,
and hit run.
This should work fine.
But if you want to see
more, like I mentioned,
control w would go to the
reference page online.
And you can go through
everything here and understand
and read more if you want to.
So let's go back to them, not
going to focus on container,
we had the intention to
create compute before, right?
So let's go back to our
original example, compute.
Let's go through instances.
And we will create but you
see all the available commands
here.
Let's hit Create.
And perfect.
I see the syntax here.
The next thing I
need to give a name.
Let's give a name stage VM.
And this is it.
This should work, right?
I run it.
So this is going to take
a couple seconds to create
the VM, but you get the idea.
You had no idea how to run the
compute command on a container
command.
We discovered it.
we saw the usage, and basically
we created the compute instance
without hitting any
errors and successfully
ran the command here.
So with this.
Oh.
Just on time, it just
created the instance.
So I will exit from
this shell mode,
and will show you
more advanced feature.
Now we know how to run commands,
but most of you probably want
to take this and automate these
VR flaws with your script ,
right?
So in order to do,
that I will show you
some advanced feature
to empower your script.
So lets run the command.
That will list us all the
instances we created, including
the one that we just created.
See in here, stage VM is the
one we just created running
and prior to our demo, I
created some instances,
I terminated some of
them just to give you
a feeling of how it looks like.
So now, when you
run this command,
you get human readable summary.
But in your scripts, you
prefer to get a format that
is computer readable, right?
So we support formats like
yaml, JSON, CSV, and more.
So if we run the same
command, bypassing
the format flag
equals to JSON, we
would get exactly
the same result,
but in JSON with more fields
available for your scripting.
Let me clear now and let me
run the same command instances
list.
OK.
How about next
step, maybe you are
only interested in the VM
that is currently running.
So you can go ahead and
programmatically filter out
the ones that is running,
but you don't need to.
We also have a command for
you that is dash dash filter.
When we do that, you can specify
any fields equals to any value,
so we can get the field
to by [INAUDIBLE].
So we wanted status
equals the running, right?
Let's run it and perfect.
This gave me just
the running one.
So you don't need to
programmatically do that.
And I also want to mention
that you can mix and match
the filter and format.
Remember earlier we only
did the format for JSON.
We could also get
specific value.
We don't need, maybe we are
only interested in getting
the name of the VM, so we
will say a new name run it.
Perfect.
We get just values of the names.
And as a next step, what we
could do, take this command
and paste it to maybe to compute
instances delete, as an input.
So you want to delete
after you are done,
so you just paste the
names to another command.
So you can pipe the output as
an input to another command.
So you can create more
sophisticated workflows
this way.
So with this, we also
have more functionalities
that is built in for you,
like sorting, you can label,
and you can do some formatting
for day dates and things
and many more.
So I encourage you to go
through the documentation
and see other features that
could empower your scripts.
With this I am
done with my demo,
let's go back to our slides.
Perfect.
So today we took the journey
of installing Cloud SDK.
And we initialized that to
be able to talk to services.
We picked our user name.
We get the project.
We set some compute
song by default.
We created the configuration.
Right, and then we moved
on to see some components.
We ran through the components
of bq, gsutil, [INAUDIBLE]
alpha commands, beta
commands, and specifically
for a alpha command today,
we saw an interactive shell
that lets you get to
auto prompting or flags
and commands.
So you don't need to context
switch as you are typing.
This is a perfect tool for
you to discover new commands
or discover the usages.
Then we took the journey
of discovering a container
builder, and then we moved
and we created a computer VM
together.
Then we moved to create more to
see some more advanced features
like filtering,
formatting, and just
to give you an idea to
empower your scripts
and automate these workflows.
Flaws
So, as a next step,
i really, highly
encourage you to install SDK.
Please get the alpha components.
Try to run GCloud alpha shell,
and please give us feedback
by running GCloud
feedback command.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
With that, I will
give it to Omar
to cover client libraries next.
OMAR AYOUB: Thanks, Aylin.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
Still works.
Awesome.
So client libraries.
so we looked
at how to use the Cloud Shell,
how to run commands and tools,
how to use the cloud
SDK, again, everything
in the shell array using ACLI.
Now we're going to talk more
about programmatic access
to our APIs.
So we have cloud APIS, we
have many of them, 35 plus.
And what is an API ultimately?
It's an interface.
You get a version that expects
parameters, request body,
and you get a response,
you have to parse it.
Now, of course, you could go
and use the endpoint directly
and literally code against the
endpoint and do all of that
off and request in
response parsing yourself,
but clearly, this is a talk
about making things easier.
So that would not
be fun for anyone.
Not fun to get started, and
also not fun to just keep going.
Right?
So ultimately you want to
have client libraries that
allow you to connect
to these services
in a fun, idiomatic way.
So, in cloud, like I
said, we have about 30
plus APIs, 35 plus.
About a third of those are
now using the new Google Cloud
client libraries.
So we haven't covered
all of them yet,
we're working on that,
but a good third of them
are ready for you to go and
play with and have fun with.
And the whole idea is to make
these libraries more usable,
a simple interface, idiomatic,
and more importantly,
well documented.
Because it can have the
best library in the world,
if you don't have
samples to get started,
and good examples to keep going,
and more tutorials for how
to guides, you'll probably,
you know, at some point,
get frustrated.
And heads up, we actually
support seven languages here
as well.
Again, go Java dotnet,
PeachPy, Python,
node, Ruby, and everything
is open source on GitHub.
So again, we'll
just jump directly
to showing you how
to use basically
this programmatically.
So.
Never mind, we switch
back to the demo.
So, actually we're going to
walk through user journey, very
simple ones.
So you've probably
heard about, obviously,
the machine learning APIs.
It's a big deal, rightfully so.
And probably the vision API.
So imagine you're curious about
it, you want to make use of it,
how can I call it?
So first thing you probably do
is just search for it, right?
So we'll walk through
that flow and see
how you'll be able to make
a call as a quick start.
So we do a quick search, we see
the second line here beautiful
is the Cloud Vision API.
So if you haven't seen
it yet, the cloud vision
is you sent us to a service,
an image, we analyze it
and we return to
you back a response
with what is in that picture.
Right?
And then that
analysis, with labels,
with scoring, and
all of the above.
And in fact, if you scroll
a little bit on that landing
page, you notice
there's a try the API.
I highly encourage you to try
it out if you haven't done yet.
So you can just drag
and drop a photo.
I think we have one ready even.
Perfect.
And it's the cat.
Drag and drop it.
Just to show you the kind of
information we'll get back.
It's simple to pick up cat,
99% accuracy or scoring.
It's a mammal vertebrate.
So you get all these labels
back directly, thanks to the API
returning you this information.
And by the way, you'll
notice a bunch of extra data,
like web properties, you
can see a color gradient,
also it can give you back.
And finally, you also
have the JSON response,
if you want it to
parse the JSON.
Great.
But you're a
developer, so you want
to be able to call
this programmatically.
So we your going to go
ahead and click on the View
documentation to go a little
bit more then what we have here.
So this is a very
standard documentation.
We explain to you stuff.
Well, one thing that we're
to bring to your attention
is that in the
reference section,
there is a client libraries
place or item, rather.
If you click on that, that will
open the client libraries page.
This is why I'm saying
we're adding more and more
of these across of cloud APIs.
And the whole point is to
show you how to get started.
So how do I install the library,
how to set up off and then how
to make an API call.
So, just for fun we'll try it
in Node.js, see what happens.
Any node developers in
the room, by the way?
Yeah?
Yeah.
OK.
Got some It's perfect.
So
We'll just open, you know,
we'll copy the installation.
Open a terminal, and then,
are we in the right place?
Yes we are.
Perfect.
We'll just empty and install.
While this is
installing, we'll go back
to the actual
documentation and just
copy the code at the bottom.
Yeah.
Perfect.
And then open Sublime.
We'll just use Sublime for this
case, and create a new file.
That will call vision.js.
So just to walk you
through, really quickly,
and on happening here.
So we basically
import the module.
Then we have to
set a project ID.
Our project is
called next-sanfran,
but the moment you've created
initially you log onto GCP
and you're in that
console UI, you
create a project is your first
thing, you put the ID here.
You incentiate the client, then
you specify a local resource
in this case of what is the file
you want to analyze the image,
and then you call
the tech labels.
That's it.
Now in our case, we
don't have wake up cats,
so if you open where we have,
actually, the resources.
We call it picture
just to and then
you'll notice that it's
actually the Eiffel Tower.
So, we're going to ask the
Vision API to figure out
where the heck this is.
So back to the terminal,
we'll just run a basically.
The terminal actually.
Oh sorry.
She's better than me.
You can tell.
A note, pass, and vision.
what we get back is a bunch
of labels, which is perfect.
Tower landmark, monuments.
Everything you would
expect from this, right?
The thing is, we know
this is the Eiffel Tower.
So how come we didn't
get the Eiffel Tower?
Because we asked for labels.
We didn't ask for a landmark.
So just a heads
up, if you go back
to the cloud
documentation, there's
always these how-to
guides that we have.
And these are meant to show
you how to do something.
And given that this is
an API, the whole point
is to show you how to do
different calls on the API
and how to make use of the API.
So if you click here
on detecting landmarks,
you'll notice that
we want to show you
in our seven languages,
right, all of the samples
and all of the
examples per language.
If there's language
missing or two missing,
it's just because it's coming.
We're working hard at
adding all of that.
But again, to make
you productive.
So in this case, GS is selected.
You look at the example.
It's pretty much the same as
the quick start we saw earlier.
Only difference
is at the bottom,
we're calling
detecting landmarks.
Great.
As simple as that.
We can copy this, go back to
the code, update the call.
And then, oh yeah.
Perfect.
And if we execute it,
you'll notice that it will--
well, let's not
predict the future.
There we go.
It figured out that it
was the Eiffel Tower.
Notice that there was no
scoring on this, because this
is a non-verbals version.
But if you wanted to
make it more verbose,
you can have and pass
a bunch of options.
And for that, one
last quick thing,
if we go back to the client
libraries page, at the bottom
there's always an additional
resources that we're adding.
Just to let you know,
you have links over there
to basically the API
reference documentation,
you have links to
the source code.
You want to ask a question
on Stack Overflow.
And, just to let you know,
within the client library
reference, so the
API reference, we're
adding a lot of
examples, also, in there.
Just to make sure that as
you're learning about the API,
looking at different
methods, we also
have an example right there
to help you to make it simple.
And lastly, everything is on
GitHub, so just as an FYI,
if you go into Google cloud
platform organization,
we have all of these repos.
Google Cloud NODE, Google Cloud
Ruby, in all seven languages.
Now, if you're
wondering, is that, how
come we talked about the
seven languages earlier
with the Cloud Shell,
we're talking about
now seven languages with
libraries, is that coincidence?
Well, actually it's not.
There is a cloud GCP wide
effort of bringing you
forth the seven languages
as first class citizens.
We want to make sure that, as a
developer, when you come to GCP
and you want to put on your--
My language lens and be able
to look at GCP from that lens,
we have the
documentation for you
and the tools for you and
things to get you started.
So, if you actually go
to cloud.google.com/docs,
at the very, very top, you'll
notice that there's a bunch
of languages.
These are the languages
that we support.
In fact, if you click
on Java, for instance,
you'll see that this is
a landing page for Java.
We have quick start.
We have tutorials.
We have code samples.
All of that with the idea
of, you're a Java developer,
you want to learn about
this in a Java reality,
with a Java lens.
Right?
We've got you covered.
So you can learn about App
Engine Flex, App Engine Center,
all of that using Java.
In this case, if
you click on Tools,
we also have a bunch of tools
for you as a Java developer.
Remember how in the console
UI, we used a debugger,
we used, ultimately, to
class those repositories,
all these tools
that we had for you.
Well, if you're
a Java developer,
you probably use an IDE, right?
So, until inteli-J, or Eclipse.
So we kind of need to
have all of these tools
directly in your
IDE, so we don't
have to move away from your IDE,
and stay in your environment
and work from there.
So, in the last
part of the demo,
we'll actually show you that.
So we've already preinstalled
the IntelliJ plug-in,
and IntelliJ itself,
and if you open here,
we already have a project
created. , So just a heads up,
if you were to go to the App
Engine Flex documentation,
there is a quick start there as
well, that has a code sample.
So we basically just git
clone the repo, which
is called Getting Started
Java, and you notice
there's also some code there.
So if you wanted to look
into this a bit more,
I encourage you to go into
the App Engine Flex Java
quick start.
But all we do, is that
we install IntelliJ,
we install the plug-in,
we Git clone in the repo.
So now we're ready to go, and
we have that open right here.
If you look, it's very simple.
All we do again is the Hello
World, and we do a do get.
Right?
We handle the get request.
So we want to show some of
the tools we have in IntelliJ,
but before doing that, just make
sure that Java developers know
we have some love
for them as well.
It's also as easy to get started
with the client libraries.
So in this case, we'll
just use a Translation API.
Translation API, another one
of our machine learning APIs.
If you go to a client
libraries page,
now that you know about
it, you see that we have,
in this case, our
Maven dependency.
So we can hop back to
the Getting Started,
open the pump file, and then
just add this as a dependency.
Great.
This is done, and now we can
copy paste, also, the code.
So, just to explain
what the code does.
Ultimately, it incentiates
the client, right,
defines what text we want to
translate from one language
to another, and therefore,
after that, we simply
have a source language
and the target language.
So in this case, we just
copy pasted the imports,
and I will copy paste this part.
Lovely.
And then you see here,
we translate from English
to Russian.
We'll probably just try French,
just Eiffel Tower moments.
And then we can just.
Yeah.
Perfect.
And Yeah.
Obviously, we're now
printing this to the console,
since we want to return
this to the browser,
we'll just update
what we return back.
So, by the way, we also
installed the Jetty plug-in,
so if, as a web server, you
might use something else.
Tomcat, for example.
But in this case,
Jetty works well.
If we run this,
this will basically
do a local testing
of the web app
and then we'll just
show you how quickly
and how easy it is while
Jetty is loading this.
And if you do a quick zoom,
for those know French,
hello world is Bonjour le Monde.
We got it.
That simple.
That quick.
That easy.
Cool.
And, the last
piece, really, here
is just to make it
clear is that, we
talked about doing all these
workflows and the cloud UI.
You can say like, Do gits, push
to cloud source repositories,
as a remote repo, do debugging,
upload your App Engine.
Well, because we
installed the cloud tools
for IntelliJ plug-in,
if you click on tools,
you'll notice that we have
the Google Cloud tools menu
or entry here, and you can do
exactly what we did earlier.
You can set up the
Cloud source repo there.
You can attach to a
debugger, and do live debug.
You can deploy to App Engine
standard and App engine flex.
In fact, if you click on
Deploy your App Engine,
you'll notice that you can
select your project ID,
you can set some information
about your application,
just like we did earlier,
and push it up to App Engine,
and have it run and
scale up and scale out.
So Yeah.
That was that part.
We can switch back
to the slides.
Lovely.
So again, the whole point
here is that we want to make
the developer experience
easier, so you want to use Node,
you want to use Go, .NET.
We want to give you client
libraries that are easy to use,
well-documented.
We look at vision with Node.js,
we look at the Translation API
with Java, disk cloud
tools and for IntelliJ.
But we have that for Eclipse,
we have that for Visual Studio.
Again, all with the
idea of meeting you
where you are as a developer.
And if you want to learn more
about each of these languages,
I recommend going to one of
these language documentation
set, and learn about the
tools that we have for you,
and we'll keep adding,
them making them better
with the developer in mind.
Great.
We can jump in to the wrap up.
So, this is
everything we covered.
Cloud shell.
Cloud SDK.
Cloud client libraries.
And if you want to dig
deeper, in more of these,
I suggest looking
at these talks.
So, some of them already
happened yesterday.
Some of them are happening,
I believe, this afternoon
and tomorrow.
Ruby, I think, is
right after this.
If you want to
learn more about how
we're supporting
your language in GCP,
[INAUDIBLE] is something
that you want to look at.
And also, the videos
will be online,
so you might was
to look into that.
And finally, as
next steps, sign up
if you're interested
in cloud shell.
You can do cloud shell pro.
Sign up at this bit/ly link.
Learn about it.
Let us know what you think.
We want to make sure
that we hear you.
Download the latest Cloud
SDK, just like Aylin
was saying, to try out the alpha
features and play with that,
and you can send feedback
at GCloud feedback.
[INAUDIBLE] back.
And then, try to
client libraries.
For everything we
talked today, you
can go to this link,
which is a GitHub repo
Next-17 under my username.
Just to see all the
stuff we talked about,
links, and the form
for Cloud Shell pro.
So everything will
be in one place
so that you can
refer back to this.
If you have
questions for me, you
can also just file and issue.
I'll be happy to answer.
And that was it.
That's it.
Cool.